Олег Михайлик тре ніс цьому мюнхенському кабану і загадує бажання - здоров’я і сил.
Після замаху у вересні минулого року і клінічної смерті у нього проблеми з руками.
Спочатку пальці зовсім не розгиналися.
Зараз вже краще, але великий палець не дотягується до інших.
Щоб його дотягнути до долоні, треба робити ось так.
Тому що сам він поки що не хоче дотягуватися.
І якщо зробити кулак, то його теж треба сюди вставити. Тоді можна зробити кулак.
У Мюнхені півтора тижні тому йому зробили операцію - витягли кулю з легені.
Це перші прогулянки містом Олега з дружиною після виписки з лікарні.
Йому ще складно дихати.
Хірургам разом із кулею довелося вирізати ось таку частину легені.
Так і передали це все німецьким правоохоронцям.
Олег не довіряє українській поліції та прокурорам.
Боїться, що кулю можуть підмінити або загубити.
Правоохоронні органи України відверто саботували,
починаючи з надання мені пластикового пакету, щоб я привіз цю кулю сам,
і тоді її ніяк не можна було б долучити до матеріалів справи як речовий доказ,
і закінчуючи тим, що Генпрокуратура до останнього часу не спромоглася зробити ці документи
щодо міжнародної правової допомоги.
Тому є побоювання, що будуть шукати когось - когось зробити винним,
а не шукати реально тих, хто виконував це замовлення на вбивство,
а про тих, хто замовник реально, не говориться навіть зараз.
Олег наполягає, щоб експертиза вилученої кулі проводилася саме в Німеччині.
Щоб місцеві спеціалісти все задокументували, описали і лише після цього передали Україні.
Олег скаржиться, що українські правоохоронці не розслідують справу і сумнівається,
і сумнівається, що підозрювані, яких затримали, це справжні виконавці.
У Нацполіції на запит DW досі не відповіли, а у Генпрокуратурі лише підтвердили,
що надіслали до Німеччини запит про передачу Україні вилученої кулі
для експертизи та медичної документації.
На практиці в рамках міжнародної правової допомоги
німецька прокуратура, як правило, робить те, про що її просять колеги з іншої країни.
Але цей випадок може бути особливим, і німецький прокурор може ухвалити рішення
спершу провести експертизу і вже потім повернути кулю, якщо вважатиме,
якщо вважатиме, що це в інтересах правосуддя і постраждалого.
Німецька прокуратура утримується від коментарів.
Те, що німецька сторона не дає коментарів,
не означає, що вони не роблять цю експертизу прямо зараз.
На мою думку, як ми це обговорювали з німецьким прокурором, німецькою поліцією,
що вони експертизу будуть робити прямо в той самий день, коли хірурги зробили операцію.
Тому факт того, що немає коментарів - це зовсім непогана справа.
Це значить, що щось відбувається.
Бо якби вони зараз просто віддали цю кулю в Україну,
то вони б просто сказали, що ми не проводимо ніяких заходів,
ми віддали кулю українським правоохоронцям.
За словами адвоката Олега Михайлика,
якби українські правоохоронці справді були зацікавлені розкрити справу,
вони не були б проти експертизи кулі в Німеччині.
Саша Боровик сподівається, що експертизу кулі проведуть мюнхенські судмедексперти,
які мають усі необідні технічні засоби і репутацію.
Головне, щоб потім цю кулю долучили до справи як речовий доказ.
Адвокат побоюється, що українські правоохоронці можуть шукати підстави,
щоб цього не зробити.
Вартість операції та перебування у лікарні, а це майже 18 з половиною тисяч євро,
оплатив німецький уряд.
Адвокат це сприймає як сигнал українській владі, що на цю справу не можна заплющувати очі.
У Мюнхені Олег разом з дружиною відвідав один із символів міста - собор Фрауенкірхе,
одна з пам'яток якої ось цей відбиток ноги - так званий "слід диявола".
В організації замаху на своє життя Олег вбачає слід нинішньої міської влади Одеси,
хоча погрози були і раніше - ще декілька років тому.
Мені на телефон приходило: "заспокой свого чоловіка",
і один раз, коли я з магазину поверталась, також до мене підходив один хлопець
і теж казав: заспокой свого чоловіка, бо постраждають діти.
Заспокоюватись Олег не збирається.
Жартує, що набереться сил і поки пофотографує химер кам’яних,
як ці на будівлі мюнхенської ратуші, а потім боротиметься вже із живими в Одесі,
зокрема із нелегальними забудовниками.